hey folks welcome back to gays flat
stage right here the electronic triple
it's time to talk about fractured
buttholes no no wait for this one thing
little okay it's a single one the
fractured butthole Jason's two words I'm
so sorry names on red x should butthole
thank you so much for come on to talk to
myself as my plants live out your
beautiful fractured butthole hmm
congratulations you did a great little
bit on the whole the whole place is
falling apart and you come down here
right around that was that was your time
on the stage trying to wrangle tray and
Matt I was it was fun it was
exhilarating I barely remember it like
his sort of an adrenaline rush yeah we
had good did a single rehearsal right
and it was not anything like the one we
did live so pretty pretty fun good the
main thing is just uh we meet very very
very regularly so I like all the game
design meetings you're basically like
let's just go up there and kind of have
a meeting it's like I have some prepared
videos right I need to make sure we hit
so you guys will say some stuff and
everyone so i'll go back story we should
talk about backstory really great video
about it yeah what's that what's that
relationship like I guess like how
involved it seemed like they were
incredibly evolved in the stick of truth
writing the whole thing is that the same
case you mean they were right there
they're like the creative directors and
the lead writers and like the head
editorial and it's like they're super
duper involved like I think that they
could be making a movie they could be
making another play but yeah choosing to
sort of divert all that energy and
making a great game yeah and it was
really interesting watching sort of the
series after the stick of truth because
there was so much random video game
related stuff yeah in there like you
could tell they were like visiting
websites and read it and stuff like that
yeah I think that you anytime you watch
an episode and you're like where do they
come up with that yeah it's just what
they're thinking about it's just what
they're that's very personally doing and
see there the boys are saying stuff for
Randy saying stuff so what's it been
like for you then working do you work on
cicatriz as well right I was working on
rocksmith with that okay all right so
what I guess what's the what's the sort
of impetus
doing the sequel has it come from those
guys was there sort of unfinished
business left in that or have you guys
dragged in like a bunch of people who
hadn't wouldn't have played a sad part
game before and you kind of want to
service them again well I think it's a
few things like Ubisoft was really happy
with how the stick of truth was received
and then I think South Park was like
well I mean people liked it but what if
we did it even better right like oh well
we wouldn't want to do that and it's
like well but if we did do it it would
be about superheroes because we really
liked the [ __ ] and friends like yeah
what would we call it and then I think
he's like the fractured but hahaha okay
we have to make cuz now I want to see
that on a giant billboard and I was like
and we'll get you these off to pay for
it done you just completed a recently
right yeah I didn't I've been putting it
off for so long for some reason that my
roommate is like right he heard we I
hadn't played and he's like okay let's
play yeah and just like from the outset
I played undertale right before that
right and there's very different games
but they're also like kind of play with
what you expect from RPGs very much like
in the classes of stick of truth
especially mmm is I don't know what's
appropriate to say on the stage and any
of any trepidations we already said
fractures but whole bunch yeah I guess
so but no it's exactly as a Jew yes okay
I'll get it out of there for ya no it's
uh and then obviously the whole when
you're picking your name whatever is
like are you sure it's not douchebag
okay yeah leave you into a douche bags
yeah yeah no I didn't I yeah I think you
entered douchebag alright confirmed
douchebag so what type of sequel is the
fracture but hole that is it like are
you are you using those same or PG
mechanics and layering on a new story or
yeah but it moves some new stuff in
there it's this you're the new kids
still from stick of truth so like the
familiarity of the town and everything
will feel really good but I think sick
of truth ended up being largely a sort
of satirical but all games and this is a
little bit satirical about movies and
entertainment and general just sort of
everyone it's funny that everyone like
that's just a normal like mass-market
person at this point understands an
origin story and conflict and crooked
cops and like what you need to do to be
a superhero these days and
just like the citizens of South Park
kind of getting caught up in the kids
game and just being a part of their
their sort of fantasy so does it play
similarly to stick a truth kind of will
people be used to that I mean cuz the
what there's an element of if it ain't
broke don't fix it there but then you
know you make sure you wanna let me know
you were able to finish stick of truth
in pretty short order and like I think
we still want that level of you know
Ubisoft has games that can take you a
lifetime to complete I told you
everything and doesn't show that you
know this one this one I mean we want it
to it's big but it's we wanted people to
not feel like they're I'm never gonna be
able to finish that right that's nice so
for fractured i think that the combat is
obviously a big change so the last time
it was turn-based just you each stick on
a side and this time is still turn based
which gives us a lot of flexibility to
get in jokes right timing and have you
to have the time to hear the joke
delivered but it also we wanted more
depth so we we really we were talking
about it kind of sucks that when you're
able to like explore around south park
but then we have this little cut away
and then you're kind of fighting in an
approximation of the place you were just
right yeah we like we really want to
just have a fight in that kitchen we
want to have a fight in Cartman's
kitchen we're going to fight on Main
Street not an approximation and so in
order to do that we're like well why
would you have to no longer be able to
move if you were just exploring so yeah
okay well let's move and then I realized
oh my god I just quadrupled or maybe a
couple the amount of animation work we
have to do but totally worth it because
now you can like knock each other around
and really just water you see okay yeah
those are time farts totally talk about
it well I'm low down time when you fart
it changes the turn order if you do it
during combat let's go in a turn-based
game if you can manipulate the turn
order it's one of those weird things of
the boys are always imagining that
they're superheroes but somehow they're
always kind of also having a real impact
on the world yeah there's there's a sort
of weird mind game of are you really
farting so bad that it's breaking time
or is everyone just agreeing to switch
up the turmeric turner because you are
you still have I'm sorry you still have
like character archetypes you choose
from for your character like not classes
but kind of you know we have
classes actually we took the superhero
class types though that you might play
in like a super hero tabletop RPG and so
you could be a speedster blaster or like
a brick so you could be like a thing
quiksilver Cyclops and sort of mix and
match those powers though that you like
have a defensive thing but you can be
move fast and shoot blasters because
your kids and it's just sort of like
revising the rules based on yeah yeah
okay okay you can have another class but
you know you have to have this new
kryptonite or whatever like just they're
just making stuff up yeah yeah there's a
bunch of questions coming in ok Oh many
of them I can't possibly say but keep
them coming in at did you change change
the town of San Park asks if the mat GUI
or is the map the same so we have you
even like deal with that considering
like it exists or there's a surfer
cannon you as the new kids still live
next door to butters great and butter so
there's next door to Eric so it's that
sort of familiar stuff is there but then
at the same time we needed to add new
businesses so because in a superhero
show you need that sort of like dirty
place that you go to so we have like the
peppermint hippo which is there strip
club and Luka two [ __ ] Cheney which
is their Italian restaurant I was like
oh okay bukit a [ __ ] chica is the
peppermint hippo in any way a play on
spearmint rhino never heard of that was
that was a place we saw recently uh
we're in like Santa Barbara on the drive
down and see the key action I know I
sure yeah yeah alright but like the VA
we have the ruins of soda so power still
built up around Kenny's house from the
last season so you can cited sort of see
like season 19 blending into this
version of south park am I was gonna ask
something and then you mentioned the
spearmint rhino I completely got out of
my head and I guess when training Matt
were on the stage they talked about the
kanye west and I sort of like a moment
so yeah that might be that's not
actually in the game that that exists
that is actually a nice gay fishes mom
get to heaven okay so it's gonna be
emotional for everyone it's like it's
like internal it's like you have a game
within a game
yeah almost yeah yeah I mean they've
added value in the last game you go into
Canada and just sort of the stuff that
kind of takes your expectations and
subverts it like we're definitely still
finding that sort of stuff and just
trying to get you to just not just do
the same thing every moment I do you've
anything it like walk games those guys
play did I ever come to you and say like
oh look I've been playing a bunch of
this well that's what makes it really
easy to collaborate with them is that
they are both big gamers so just like
you know when you're working on with
game developers and you're like well you
know like this i was playing this this
weekend and no they did this really
smart thing the same exact way like
right right now not not because of a
Ubisoft thing Matt Stone is playing the
division right easy so that that's a
really good touchstone for us to talk
about oh well the reason they did that
and we could do something like that in
our game really unifies that language
Trey has been playing a lot of RPGs but
he also plays a ton of tabletop game
right oh he's a dungeon master and runs
his own campaign oh really um and for
for him then all of those mechanics and
a lot of those like tactics things that
we're doing are also things that he sort
of you know just like a good game design
lead he's like well I you know let's
prototype it in a little bored rhyme
scenario it doesn't get irritating when
they're like cuz like to me that sounds
like every person on the Internet era
it's like oh you should have done it
like that I really like this part of
like The Witcher could you like stick
that yeah when you have editorial
control you could totally say that if
you I got a bit of like it was like
Stanley parable esque stuff with Cartman
narrating over yeah yeah so what you're
seeing there is actually Cartman uh has
an interactive back story with you so
you go to Cartman who's the [ __ ] and he
is trying to build up his franchise and
he wants you to be a marketable super
hero because he wants you to be a part
of making a billion dollars for him and
so that means that you need to have a
compelling backstory and what we did is
we used that interactive backstory to
actually train you on your new powers
God so if you unlock a speedster rather
than just throwing you out in the world
like you were a June you're like I have
no idea what that's going to mean but
yet long-term consequence and now you're
locked in but what's the big pop pick
like all role-playing games yes so you
choose speedster and he gets to do it
like you did you like those powers would
you like to try something else like no
matter what you're never going to be in
time to stop your day
add from how much can I say you just
went through yes you'll never be in time
to stop your dad from [ __ ] your mom
okay like no matter what that's that's
the the problem with being a superhero
that's just you know has that painful
origin story I'm sparks be asking at
will the new upcoming season estar prac
influence the game or vice versa or any
crossover does that sort of stuff happen
uh I mean there's like elements of the
seasons you can see in the game I mean
we're coming out in December and south
park season 2 1 will be 20 will be
running from sep tember to December so I
think it's much more likely to hit DLC
than it is the game just like because
they don't know what they're doing in
season 20 right right now like
legitimately no idea they will walk in
in September and go what it's on our
minds and let's get that under the
screen in six days I feel so older there
are 20 seasons of south park like that's
my remember being like a feeling like I
was like an old person like an older
teenager when they start of that I guess
been ridiculous oh yeah it's I think
people have sort of grown up and had
their minds twisted by it right who do
you who buys this game do you think was
like I don't even who the audience for
because the audience for safer like me
the audience reset back is like people
like our age you grew up watching it but
presumably they're like younger folks
watching as well one of these weird
things about stick is that like we start
seeing people playing it online and then
they've start playing it because I saw
someone else playing it online by
sharing those videos and then they're
like man this games so great did you
hear they made a cartoon out of it are
you kidding me is that I think Wow well
that's such a weird way to approach that
like we just never really anticipated it
so now with fractured we just like we
want we want moms to play it and that
seems like it's a weird thing like well
moms it's like no man moms have become
moms while South Park has been right and
no God has in her running right oh my
god so someone's dad dr. Cox that's
right and now but she's still in the
South Park totally get in there and play
cuz we were trying to make something
that's both like a good game and like
gamers are gonna feel like cool it's a
tactics game and I get it right but you
know if you just want to experience it
you shouldn't be intimidated and like
all those jokes are there for you as
well last thing like the first would
stick it kind of seemed initially like
it would be tough to sell
you have South Park fans which will go
for it then like people start playing a
little by little they're like no it's
not just a southpark game it's like a
good RPG is that like i imagine it's a
little easier to wrap your people's
heads around fractured butthole right on
the second time around and they kind of
know what a day is right yeah yeah
there's a level of expectation that
we're definitely going to have to hit it
and go beyond it and I think we
definitely do that with combat and being
able to explore the environments and
really you know we've just improved on
everything that the farting is more
visceral and interactive than ever
before and there's emergent farts now oh
yeah sure they're definitely analog
farts it's really important that like
both analog sticks are controlling sort
of a sphincter and gas pushing sort of
right yeah really yeah emergence ort of
visceral as you said next gen man yeah
it's wonderful what a wonderful age we
live in yes just thank you so much Jason
no problem with lightning on my
afternoon access parking fractured
butthole when is it out in autumn all
platforms december six from playstation
4 xbox one and pc just in time for the
holidays right thank you so much for
your time my pretty appreciate enjoy the
rest of your electronic triple i will be
back in just a minute folks thank you so
much for all of your questions
especially the ones i could not poss oh
my god Lisa so fangs of a bit of a
change of pace we're gonna have David
cage on in a second to talk have had to
try I've become home and become human so
I stick around you're watching the game
spot stage brought to you by airheads